hello everybody I'm Dan Morel host of
Summer Movie report with Dan Merlyn
screen junkies plus and this is my
spoiler review for finding dory if you
want to read my non-spoiler thoughts you
can check out my written review right
now live on screen junkies com so last
warning if you don't want to get sort of
spoiled on finding dory there's not much
to spoil you can check out that review
now otherwise let's get to the review
now finding Dory is of course the latest
movie from Pixar and I can't think of
another studio that has tweaked and
perfected a formula as masterfully as
Pixar for better for worse they
basically all run on the same formula
you have a group of characters who have
a thing one or two of them gets
separated from that thing they then have
to team up to find the thing and then at
the end once they find the thing there's
a big emotional moment now there's a
danger with that formula for a while
Pixar was money in the bank it was an
instant success but then you got movies
like cars - and the good dinosaur and
all of a sudden a Pixar movie being
great isn't necessarily a slam dunk so
is finding Dory great I would not put it
at the level of a movie like inside out
or wall-e but I also wouldn't put it at
the lower end like a cars - or a good
dinosaur what fighting Dory does is take
the Pixar formula and deliver exactly
what you want to see from a Pixar movie
now the first part of finding Dory
actually does kind of come off as a
retread for the first 2025 minutes I was
watching kind of going oh no they're
just doing Finding Nemo again you're in
the same settings you have exactly the
same characters but where this movie
really starts to take off is when Dory
actually leaves the ocean and you find
yourself in the marine life Institute
where the bulk of the movie takes place
that's where you meet your main
characters your new characters and
that's also where you kind of depart
from Nemo and Marlin now going into the
movie I kind of thought that Dory would
be the one that would kind of be a
one-note character and the Nemo and
Marlin from the first movie would prop
Dory up a little bit and I actually
found it to be the opposite I was
actually much more invested in Dory her
story and the new characters the stuff
with Nemo and Marlin I kind of felt
obligatory it kind of felt like those
characters were included because people
would want them to be included from
Finding Nemo so that's one thing the
finding Dory does well and it
transitions your sympathy over to dory
you're invested in her story you're
invested in the new characters more than
you are in the old characters that's one
of the reasons why this movie still
comes off fresh now the standout
character in this movie I thought was
Hank the octopus voiced by Ed O'Neill
now this is maybe one of the funnier
characters that's been in any Pixar
movie it's a supporting character but
that's a lot of times where you find the
most humor he's not a bing-bong he's not
an emotional supporting character he's
there for comic relief but he's really
funny there's also a lot of new voices
in supporting roles including Ty Burrell
and Kaitlin Olson as a couple of whales
Diane Keaton Eugene Levy voicing Tori's
parents and because this is a Disney
animated film in 2016 apparently it just
Alba has to be in it voicing an animal
he voices one of two seals the other one
is Dominic West and they actually
although they're not in the movie very
very much are really really funny I
laughed every time they were on-screen
and again it shows how Pixar can take a
small character and give them funny
business to do that really elevates the
film as a whole instead of just making
them cheap comedic things for kids to
laugh at it can get adults in the action
too I have sort of wonder over look how
stunning this film looks a lot of people
take it for granted at this point they
just assume that it's reality but every
single movie Pixar does pushes the
boundaries pushes ahead for what they're
able to achieve on screen and that's one
of the reasons that they're still at the
top of the animated game is that they
continue to challenge themselves except
for the occasional cars - I'll give you
that one
when it comes down to deciding how good
finding Dory is there's one thing that I
kind of have to keep in mind and it's
that I think there are two kinds of
Pixar movies you've got the Pixar movie
like this movie like Monsters Inc like
ratatouille that are really really
really well done family films the kids
will enjoy them that the adults will
enjoy them too but you also have the
second kind of Pixar film that's your
inside out that's your wall-e
those are the movies that transcend the
family film tag and are just great
movies in and of themselves which one is
finding dory I would say it's much more
of a well-done family film we get
spoiled with Pixar and it's not fair to
expect a transcendent movie every time
they go out not every movie is going to
be inside out well finding the way be
remembered as one of Pixar's best movies
probably not but it's not going to be
remembered as one of its worst or one of
its disappointments either finding Dory
is a solid movie it's one that the whole
fan
he's going to enjoy and it's one that I
think you will enjoy also I'm giving
finding Dory a solid B grade but here's
the thing I want to make sure that Pixar
doesn't forget as much as we love
familiar characters and as fun as
finding Dory is I hope that Pixar
doesn't lose sight of the fact that
their original movies are what
originally made people fall in love with
them yes we love returning characters
but their new ideas are always so
exciting and such a breath of fresh air
so I just hope that Pixar doesn't lose
sight of the one thing that made us fall
in love with them in the first place
their imagination so those are my
thoughts on finding Dory what did you
think did you love it did you think it
was a disappointment for Pixar let us
know the comments below we'd love to
hear from you also if you want to see us
break down the summer box office each
and every week
make sure to tune into some remover
report with dan moreau we're live on
screen junkies plus every Monday morning
at 11 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
breaking down all the box office numbers
and the movies that you need to know
about thanks for watching my review of
finding dory I'll see you next time reel
in the Pixar classic everyone took the
wrong lessons from leading to the
capture of thousands of actual Nemo's
the death of countless fish that kids
tried to free down the toilet
all drains lead to the ocean and for new
seafood restaurants were complete
sociopath